we'll talk to end the shutdown our on
hold in the relationship between the two
key figures on each side is under new
pressure President Trump abruptly denied
permission for House Speaker Nancy
Pelosi to use military aircraft for a
trip to visit troops in Afghanistan now
this follows Pelosi's request for the
president to delay his State of the
Union address during the shutdown ed
O'Keefe is on Capitol Hill and this is
getting very heated good morning
sure is beyond and a rebuke seen by many
as an extraordinary breach of security
protocol the president not only revealed
the speaker's closely-held travel plans
he also forced her to postpone them in a
letter mr. Trump told mrs. Pelosi maybe
it make more sense for her to stay here
in Washington to keep negotiating we
need strong borders the shutdown that
began over border security without a
strong border America's defenseless is
now a petty political battle with both
sides exercising rarely-used powers
speaker Pelosi began the president's
decision to delay speaker Pelosi strip
came just minutes before many Democrats
on the delegation boarded a bus for
Joint Base Andrews the bus left the
capital but then turned right around in
a letter to Pelosi the president argued
in light of 800,000 great American
workers not receiving pay I am sure you
would agree that postponing this public
relations event is totally appropriate
but just last month during the first
week of the shutdown the president used
Air Force One on a quick top-secret trip
to and from Iraq and while White House
officials insisted mr. Trump's order was
meant to encourage negotiations
Democrats were caught off guard I think
the actions of the president were petty
mean-spirited signaling the shutdown is
far from over
it's ridiculous in North Carolina young
parents Caitlyn and Chris fuller are
worried about meeting their financial
obligations we still have continued
expenditures Chris a scientist and EPA
contractor isn't guaranteed any back pay
so he's taken up substitute teaching
they're you know playing games with each
other and we're the people who are
hurting now continuing in his role as
travel agent the president has postponed
his delegations trip to next week's
World Economic Forum in Davos
Switzerland but CBS News has learned the
first lady took a government jet last
night to Florida on her way to the
family's mar-a-lago estate and we should
point out the State Department is now
recalling most of its personnel saying
it's found enough money to keep them on
the job without pay for at least two
weeks starting on Sunday John EADS thank
you and remember I was just gonna say
what's noteworthy about that is that the
president and his chief of staff make
decision about where the presidential
fleet goes they can sign off on it so
they can deny a delegation they can
allow the first lady or they can allow a
cabinet secretary but it's it's an
interesting thing about the power that
but that the executive branch holds in
terms of this aircraft and it often
comes back to aircraft you'll remember
in 1995 Bill Clinton and Speaker Newt
Gingrich got in a tussle over Newt
Gingrich's treatment on Air Force One
Gingrich said he wasn't treated very
well and that soured their budget
negotiations